earlier this month the one October  committee asked for public submissions  for a new Memorial today Clark County  unveiled the gallery with all the  Creative Expressions and submissions  received  it really is just an opportunity for  people to share how they've been  impacted in such a way that will inspire  our eventual design for the memorial now  the committee's design team will be  looking at all of those submissions and  develop a final version which is  expected to be presented to everyone  next summer you can still submit any any  ideas you have by going to the  committee's website or through its  mobile app